I said labs to you. This is a different lab. So I know I have to take that into consideration, a different lab company that this person did.
By the vitamin D 25 hydroxy is 127. So let's talk about that first. 127 on your desolators per milliliter of your vitamin D levels.
Now, most physicians will say, oh my gosh, that's really high stop take in your vitamin D.
No, I don't think so. So really you, my book, if you're a person with a cancer diagnosis, you really want your vitamin D levels, you know, between 80 and 150, that would be good.
So if it gets beyond 150 to you know, then it's time to back off on what you're taking supplement wise.
But I would say continue, unless you're looking at a trend, let's say you three months ago, your vitamin D was 80 and you started to take, you know, 10,000 I use a day.
You know, it's 127 if you continue to take 10,000 I use a day. It could be in 177 and three more months. You might want to back off on it. So look at the trends.
A calcium is 10.1 up from 9.6. Why is that significant? So calcium is another thing that you look at in your complete metabolic panel or a person with cancer because calcium levels along with alkaline phosphatase levels here are an indication of body metastasis.
Well, this person already knows they have body metastasis and we're monitoring that their calcium level is up their alkaline phosphatase is up and this is a concern that I've talked to this person about this already.
But that's what you look at. So alkaline phosphatase is an enzyme made in the liver, it will be elevated if there's damage to the liver, could be elevated with cirrhosis of the liver.
But another reason why it can be elevated is if there's if there's metastasis to bone. So if there's metastasis to bone a person's alkaline phosphatase will be up. So just when you look at one value like alkaline phosphatase, you can't say, oh, this person has body metastasis. No, you have to look at multiple different things, but this isn't indication.
Well, this person knows it has body metastasis because they had a CT scan showing that other things will happen when you have body metastasis. This year, you will have elevated calcium levels because when cancer metastasis to the bone, it's lidic that attacks the bone and starts shooting away and goblet it up.
So it'll spill calcium into the blood, raising your blood calcium. So it's a lidic lesion, it's decreasing bone density, it's a rowdy bone and it's spilling calcium into the blood.
My tumor markers also went up, I started out, I just started on a mistletoe now taking a new medication and the oncologist is switching a chemotherapy and we just started around a rebel pro, which has been shown to be really good for this type of cancer. So we hope to see these numbers change.
So this is how you try to manage yourself and manage your care as you make different changes and you look at different values and you're hoping to pray that those things change.